helicoland is a tiny Island here off the
coast of what's now Germany it belonged
to numerous States until the early 19th
century when it came into the control of
the British they stayed there for almost
a century when they handed the island
over to the new German Empire but given
the Island's valuable position off the
coast of Germany this raises the
question why did Britain give helicoland
to Germany so to go back heligoland had
belonged to many states throughout
history before it came under the control
of the Danish in the early 18th century
it remained a part of the Danish realm
into the early 19th century when the
Danish optic decide with Napoleon
against the British the Royal Navy soon
seized the island and Britain's control
over it was formalized in the Treaty of
Keel in 1814. the idea behind Britain
obtaining this minuscule Island was that
it would be built up as a naval base and
would then be used to patrol the seas
around it against France the Netherlands
and Prussia as you'll know Germany
unified in 1871 and its leaders wanted
to establish it as an industrial and
Military Powerhouse that could rival any
other and heligoland presented a major
issue due to its proximity to the brand
new Keel Canal now the British didn't
want to turn the island into a military
base but the problem for Germany wasn't
Britain using the island but everybody
else in 1848 the Danish and prussians
fought a war and the Danish were able to
blockade the Elba River and cut off
trade by using helicoland as a neutral
Safe Harbor now the Germans weren't
worried about the Danish but the French
war between the two again seemed likely
and if France's larger Navy was able to
use heliger land as Safe Harbor Germany
may find itself in trouble as such the
German government desperately wanted to
get their hands on it this led to a
series of discussions between the two
Powers which ended in Britain handing
over heliger land to Germany in 1890.
this was part of a broader deal with
Germany to further divide Africa between
them and improve relations in return for
heliger land Britain was handed this
land in East Africa and Germany agreed
not to interfere in whatever Britain did
in the area furthermore Britain
acknowledged Germany's control over this
land here the British were very happy
with the treaty having received these
lands and a free hand in the region and
all of it in return for an island that
they didn't really care for the initial
Hope Was That by taking a step away from
Germany's Coast it would improve
relation and would importantly mean that
the Kaiser wouldn't feel the need to
build up his Navy to counter Britain in
the North Sea but fun fact no in Germany
the response to the treaty was mostly
one of anger many believe that the
government had sold Germany short and
had given Britain far more than Germany
had received as a result of the Handover
many German politicians took a harder
line towards German Imperial expansion
in Africa feeling that this
embarrassment needed to be rectified by
other means two world wars later the
island once again fell under British
control as part of its occupation Zone
and thus they had to prepare the island
for a post-war existence and the British
plan was simple blow it up turns out
that's quite hard and so the British
moved to plan B give up and thus
heligoland alongside the rest of the
Allied occupation zones were
incorporated into West Germany in 1949
and it remains a part of Germany to this
day I hope you enjoyed this episode with
a special thanks to my patrons James
bizzinette Kelly moneymaker Kors show
wolf Sky Chappelle katoitska Jerry
lambdin Alex Schwinn Adam Stalter Jordan
Longley rod D Martin wine hockey Marcus
arsner Captain psydog Marvin Castle
Spencer Lightfoot Winston caywood boogly
Wiggly Daniel tabian kamoon Yoon Miss
izet Gustav Swan Aaron the white Anthony
Beckett the mcwhopper Maggie Paskowski
Coppertone spinning three plates
shewenin words about books podcast and
Charles the first